Hello everyone.
Today we're going to focus on the
languages of Singapore.
Singapore has one of the few remaining
city states in the world located in
Southeast Asia at the tip of the Malay
Peninsula.
The archipelago that makes up Singapore
is just a stone's throw away from
peninsular.
Malaysia separated from it by the
streets of Johor.
Despite being one of the smallest
countries in the world.
Singapore is a culturally and
linguistically diverse place and as one
of the world's leading financial
centers,
it continues to attract immigrants and
ex patriots from around the world.
Singapore was originally a molay trading
port called Tomasek around the 14th
century and later became known as single
Pooda.
It eventually fell into obscurity until
it was established as a British trading
colony in 1819 from 1963 to 1965
Singapore briefly became part of the new
federation of Malaysia,
which was formed from former British
colonies in the region.
It then became independent in 1965 while
under British rule,
Singapore had a free trade policy which
attracted Chinese traders and laborers
from Malaysia and China and Chinese grew
to become the majority of the
population.
Also,
Singapore and India were under British
rule at the same time,
which led to a flow of migrants from
India.
Today,
and for most of Singapore's history,
ethnic Indians have formed the third
largest ethnic group in Singapore after
Chinese and malaise.
Singapore has four official languages
that were chosen to represent the
largest ethnic groups in the country at
the time that the constitution was
written.
First English,
due to Singapore's history as a British
colony,
Mandarin Chinese to unite the large
Chinese population molay which doubles
as the national language of Singapore
because it's the language of the
indigenous population and Tamil to
represent the Indian population of
Singapore on an administrative level.
The unofficial Lingua Franca of the
country is English,
and it serves as the main language of
instruction in schools.
The language of the justice system and
the language of business.
The vast majority of Singapore ends are
bilingual as a result of the country's
education policy with 73.2%
of the population identifying as
bilingual or multilingual.
All Singaporeans are now mainly educated
in English,
but they're also required to take
courses in the mother tongue that
corresponds to their ethnic background
that so-called mother tongue doesn't
necessarily correspond to the student's
native language and it's better to think
of it as a heritage language.
Mandarin is the mother tongue assigned
to students of Chinese background,
even though the students family might
use a different Chinese language or
English at home.
Similarly,
Tamil is the mother tongue,
a scientist,
students of Indian background,
even though they may speak a different
Indian language or English at home and
Molay is the mother tongue assigned to
students molay background,
even though some may speak English or
another language at home.
Now,
let's take a look at each of the four
official languages.
English,
the official language most commonly
spoken at home is English with
approximately 36.9%
of the resident population speaking it
as their first language with the rest of
the population.
Having some level of fluency.
There are very few Singaporeans who
speak no English and amongst the younger
generation,
basically everybody speaks it fluently.
English was made the main language of
school instruction in all government
schools beginning in 1987 before that,
different schools offered instruction in
different mother tongues,
immigrants and ex pats aside.
There are two basic forms of English
that are used in Singapore.
First standards,
Singaporean English,
which is based on the conventions of
British English,
but it's spoken with a uniquely
Singaporean accent and an English creole
known academically as colloquial
Singaporean English and more popularly
known as singlish.
The standard form of the language is
highly promoted by the government of
Singapore through state sponsored
programs such as the speak good English
movement that was specifically started
in order to curb the use of English.
But why do they care if people use
singlish?
Well,
I suppose that's because they want
people to use a form of English that can
successfully be used in academic and
professional situations.
But speaking singlish doesn't mean that
you can't speak standard English.
Standard English and singlish exist
along a socio elect continuum meaning
that the form of English used depends on
the social context.
In the most formal situations people use
standard English and in the most
informal situations they might use pure
singlish and they often mix them to
varying degrees depending on the level
of formality of the situation.
Singlish is topic prominent like Chinese
or Japanese and as such many sentences,
we'll begin by mentioning the topic of
the sentence first.
Other noticeable features are that the
use of the plural form of nouns as well
as articles and the verb to be are all
optional and also the grammatical
subject can be dropped if it's clear
from the context.
Here are a couple of examples of
singlish
our drawings,
those impact how to pass
and in standard English something like
how can we get good marks with such a
simple drawing.
In this sentence we see topic prominence
with the topic placed at the beginning
of the sentence
still got heading
and in standard English I've still got a
headache.
In this sentence,
you can see that the subject isn't
included and there's also no auxiliary
verb and there's no indefinite article.
The Nisha already law
in this sentence,
the subject isn't included,
so you would only know who or what has
finished from the context of the
previous sentences and notice the word
at the end of the sentence.
La.
This word emphasizes a statement or
assertion.
There are other similar words that show
uncertainty or indicate that you're
asking a question.
These words are borrowed from varieties
of Chinese like Hokkien and in fact,
many of the features of singlish are in
those Chinese varieties.
And one more example that you can rise
restaurant over there.
See Bait the Kong,
their food dye dye must try in standard
English.
That chicken rice restaurant over there
has amazingly good food.
We've got to try it.
If it's the last thing we do,
this first sentence starts off like
standard English,
but then we see this phrase here,
seabed topcon.
Topcon is a phrase from Hokkien which
means very good and CBA is an
intensifier with the somewhat grim
etymology.
In the second sentence,
you see the topic placed at the
beginning again and there's no subject
in the sentence because it's clear from
the context and then we have this unique
adverbial phrase die,
die.
Even though the use of singlish is
discouraged by the government,
that doesn't really mean that it's on
the decline.
In fact,
to many people,
English has become a source of local
pride and identity and just as there
have been attempts to stamp it out into
diminish its use,
there has also been a significant amount
of pushback from locals who want to
prevent it from disappearing completely
mandarin after English.
The second most commonly used language
at home is Mandarin Chinese,
which is used by around 34.9%
of the resident population as a first
language.
But if we add to that,
all of the other varieties of Chinese,
which are around 12.2%
of the population than Chinese,
comprises the largest language group in
Singapore.
But to be clear,
that's a group of languages,
not just one language.
Before the Constitution of Singapore was
written.
Both Mandarin and Hokkien functioned as
Lingua Franca for the diverse Chinese
community.
When the constitution was written in
1965 the government chose Mandarin in
order to officially unite the population
and then in 1979 the government led by
Prime Minister Lee Kuan Yew started the
now annual speak Mandarin campaign to
continuously promote the use and
learning of the language instead of
other Chinese languages.
This has resulted in an increase in the
number of mandarin speakers and a
decrease in the number of speakers of
other Chinese languages and I guess that
was exactly the intention of that
program.
The form of Mandarin used in Singapore
very closely follows the conventions of
the mandarin used in China and Taiwan.
However,
just as with English,
Mandarin and Singapore has not been able
to avoid the influence of other
languages and has developed a socio
elekta continuum just as English has.
On opposite ends of the spectrum,
you have standard mandarin and sing
Durham or colloquial Singaporean
mandarin sing.
Dorin is a result of the wide adoption
of Mandarin by speakers of other Chinese
languages,
as well as contact with languages of the
other ethnic communities,
singer and seems to have some creole
elements as well as an element of code
switching,
especially with English.
The grammar is essentially mandarin with
a lot of vocabulary borrowed from other
Chinese languages,
ballet as well as English and sometimes
entire phrases or clauses or in English.
Here are a couple of sentences in sing
Durham Conan.
Next week,
how's the whole woman tie an English?
Maybe we can meet next week after I
finished my exams.
In this first sentence,
we see basically a mandarin sentence
with some English vocabulary taking the
place of Mandarin words
wait
and English.
The weather today is too hot.
I can't stand it.
In the second sentence we see an English
word and then this word boy is a Hokkien
word,
meaning cannot,
and this word [inaudible] Hahn is a
Malay word,
meaning tolerate.
These two words often appear together in
this phrase,
meaning something like,
I can't stand it.
Other forms of Chinese spoken in
Singapore apart from Mandarin and
Hokkien include guilt.
You Cantonese Haka and high knees,
but the government's promotion of
Mandarin is causing it to gradually
replace the others Malai.
The third most widely spoken of the four
official languages is molay or Bahasa
Melayu,
which is spoken by around 10.7%
of the officially resident population.
Malaya has also given special status as
the national language of Singapore as a
result of this special status.
It's used in the national anthem in
military drills and on the Singaporean
coat of arms.
Malaysia and Singapore in its standard
form is essentially the same as standard
molay as used in Malaysia and in Brunei.
In addition to standard Molay,
there's also a molay creole called Baba
Malai or Peranakan Malai,
which is endangered,
but it's still spoken fluently by some
older people.
The peranakan are the descendants of
settlers who married local malaise.
This contact of cultures resulted in a
creole language with mostly malave
vocabulary,
but with influence of Chinese grammar.
There's another similar form of molay
called Bazaar Malaysia or Malaya Pasada,
a pigeon form of my leg,
which has no native speakers.
Decades ago when English was less widely
spoken.
Bazaar molay often functioned as a
Lingua Franca.
It's now spoken mainly by some older
Singaporeans.
Here's an example of bazaar millay.
I'll give you a sentence.
Meaning when a Singaporean,
here's where goods are cheap,
he goes there first in Standard Malaya
[inaudible] Monday,
Nada,
10 Dung,
Tim Pat,
young men pony I baton Woulda,
[inaudible] huggy Kissy to a more or
less direct translation into English
would be when person of Singapore.
Here's about place that has cheap goods.
He will go to there next in bazaar,
Millay Singapore up when you're done
telling a dia de God man,
a young bud,
Buddha,
the buggy,
uh,
more or less direct translation of this
would be Singapore's person.
His ear here,
where that goods cheap,
he goes in the bazaar millay sentence,
the word for when is absent and then we
see a different way of expressing
Singaporean in standard molay.
The word [inaudible],
meaning person comes first and the
modifying word single Pooda comes after
in bazaar millay.
The modifier Singapore comes before and
followed by the modifying particle
Poonja.
This word exists in Standard Malaya and
means have an actually,
you can see it as the root of this word
right here and then Brunei.
But in bazaar molay it mimics this
Chinese modifying particle.
Let me point out one more difference in
the standard molay sentence.
You see the word for here when the God,
but in Bazaar Molay you see Donato in
bazaar,
Millay affixes are often dropped and the
word root is used instead.
Tamil,
the least widely spoken of the four
official languages is Tamil,
uh,
dravidian language that is spoken
primarily in southern India and in some
parts of Sri Lanka and has also spoken
by a significant minority in Malaysia.
It has approximately 70 million native
speakers worldwide.
In Singapore,
9.1%
of the population is of Indian
background,
but only 3.3%
speak Tamil as their main language at
home.
Many ethnic Indians speak English as
their home language or another Indian
language or my lay.
At the time when Tamil was chosen as an
official language,
it was spoken by the majority of the
Indian population of Singapore.
But the language has declined and has
now learned as a second language by the
majority of the Indian population since
it's still their assigned mother tongue.
This information we've discussed so far
includes the so called resident
population which is comprised of both
citizens and permanent residents of
Singapore.
The total resident population is about
3.9
million but there's also a large non
resident population of about 1.7
million people.
The term non resident is misleading and
you should think of them as non
permanent residents or as expatriates
because we're not talking about
tourists.
These are people who do reside in
Singapore having one of the freest
economies in the world.
Singapore has attracted a large number
of foreign companies and foreign workers
to its shores making Singapore a
cosmopolitan business and finance hub
where you can hear languages from all
over the world being spoken.
The main Lingua Franca used amongst
these diverse groups of people is
English with Mandarin.
Also serving as a Lingua Franca for the
Chinese community,
both residents and non resident with
Singapore granting permanent residence
and citizenship to new immigrants every
year.
The linguistic situation there will
certainly continue to be rich and
colorful and vibrant.
The question of the day for
Singaporeans,
what languages do you regularly speak
and in what situations do you use them?
And for other people living in
Singapore,
what language do you use most often
there?
If you speak English,
what has been your experience with
Singaporean English and singlish?
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
And once again,
thank you to all of my amazing patrion
supporters,
especially these ones right here on the
screen.
They are my top tier patrion supporters.
So many thanks to them once again and to
all of you,
thank you for watching and have a nice
day.
Okay.
Yeah.